La publicité, ça ne marche pas sur moi.
Vous avez tout à fait raison, c'est même pour ça qu'on dépense tous les ans des milliards dans la publicité.
Pour ce jeudi du hors-sujet, j'avais envie de voir pourquoi la publicité, ça fonctionne sur nous, sur quels points ça se base.
En 2004, quand Le Lay était le PDG de TF1, il avait déclaré dans une interview :
"Nous vendons du temps de cerveau disponible à Coca-Cola".
Et c'est tout à fait l'idée.
Ils veulent nous cueillir à un moment donné où on est disposé à recevoir des informations supplémentaires et inutiles.
Ce qui veut dire qu'à l'époque, pas sûr que ça ait changé depuis,
TF1 fabriquait des programmes qui nous mettaient dans un conditionnement un petit peu végétatif
pour qu'on puisse accueillir la publicité.
Laisse la publicité rentrer en toi.
Quand on regarde le mode de consommation d'une population,
on se rend compte qu'une publicité fonctionne.
Un des premiers leviers, c'est la comparaison sociale, la jalousie.
Dans une de leurs chansons, Tryo disait "ce qui ne sert à rien et rend envieux le voisin".
C'est tout à fait ça.
Qu'est ce qui va rendre envieux le voisin et qu'est ce qui nous rend envieux nous?
La plupart des personnes ont envie d'être dans la norme, qu'elles l'admettent ou pas.
Au-delà d'être dans la norme, elles ont envie d'être au-dessus de la norme,
d'être unique, d'être complètement différent, et ça, les publicitaires l'ont bien compris.
Un autre levier qui fonctionne bien, c'est le rappel.
C'est le fait de revoir une marque, un logo ou un slogan sous différentes formes et à différents endroits.
Par exemple, dans un magazine, dans la publicité télé, jusqu'à revoir le produit en tête de gondole dans un magasin.
Vous l'aurez vu souvent.
Il aura fait partie de votre quotidien.
Vous le connaissez, voir même vous le reconnaissez,
et vous avez peut-être déjà établi un petit lien de confiance, parce que, si on le voit partout, c'est qu'il y a bien une raison
Tout le marketing et le merchandising de la publicité joue sur un troisième levier qui est l'égocentrisme.
Vous allez être plus fort, vous allez être plus puissant, vous allez être plus attirant, vous allez être plus efficace,
Vous allez être plus quelque chose qu'apparemment vous êtes déjà.
Si vous allez être encore plus beau, ça signifie qu'aujourd'hui, vous êtes déjà beau.
On flatte l'ego et on nous fait croire qu'on va être encore mieux.
Mais n'oubliez jamais que nous ne sommes pas ce qu'on possède.
Donc, ce qu'on possède n'est pas ce qu'on est.
Ce n'est pas le fait d'acheter un produit qui va vous rendre cool.
Un produit n'a jamais rendu cool personne.
Ou t'es cool, ou t'es pas cool.
Pareil pour l'intelligence, la beauté, le courage, ce que vous voulez.
On ne peut pas acheter des valeurs, on ne peut pas acheter un état d'esprit.
Ca peut être cool de posséder quelque chose, mais le fait de posséder la chose ne nous rend pas cool.
Un autre levier que nos amis publicitaires aiment utiliser avec plaisir, force et conviction, c'est le conditionnement associatif et l'appartenance.
Appartenir à un groupe, à une communauté, on est comme ça.
Nous les êtres humains, on aime bien former des clans, on aime bien former des teams.
#TeamMentalos
On aime bien se regrouper.
Donc, ils vont essayer de nous faire croire qu'on va faire partie d'un groupe intéressant en possédant ce qu'ils voulaient nous vendre.
Il y a quelques années, peut-être moins aujourd'hui, il y avait vraiment les "apple" et les "windows".
Et il y avait vraiment un petit groupe : moi je travaille sur mac, ouais. C'est un autre monde, on se sent plus libre, hein.
Puis, ça ne plante jamais parce qu'il n'y a jamais de virus, c'est... tu vois, c'est euhh... c'est...
C'est cher surtout! C'était très cher, mais les arguments étaient vendus eux-même par les utilisateurs.
Ils étaient tellement fiers d'appartenir à ce groupe, fiers de leur appartenance,
qu'ils faisaient le job de commercial derrière.
Et c'est un serpent qui se mord complètement la queue, puisque, quand la personne parle de la marque ou de l'objet qu'elle a acheté que lui vendait la publicité,
elle va elle-même défendre des valeurs qui étaient encore plus fortes que les valeurs initiales de la marque.
Pourquoi? Parce que ça améliore le message qu'elle renvoie d'elle-même.
On se fait tous avoir, à petite, ou à haute dose, mais personne ne peut dire "je résiste à 100% au message des publicitaires".
Par contre, quand vous devez acheter quelque chose, que ce soit un produit ou de l'alimentaire,
faite un comparatif. Ne vous fiez plus au packaging, aux publicités que vous avez vues,
et soyez forcément pragmatique. Il faut regarder le prix, il faut regarder où est-ce que c'est fabriqué, il faut regarder les caractéristiques globales de l'appareil,...
C'est le meilleur, voire même le seul moyen de faire des actes d'achat complètement rationalisés.
Et puis si vous avez envie de craquer pour quelque chose et que vous craquez, ce n'est pas grave non plus, hein!
Merci beaucoup d'avoir regardé ce hors-sujet du jeudi, j'espère que ça vous aura plu.
Si c'est le cas, n'oubliez pas de laisser, et c'est pas une pub, un ENORME pouce en l'air.
Demain, je mentalise l'un ou l'une d'entre vous.
Je fais le tirage au sort ce soir à 20h et j'enregistre avec la personne à 21h via skype.
Si vous voulez participer, si vous voulez peut-être vous faire mentaliser dans la vidéo de demain,
alors allez voir le dernier post que j'ai mis sur la fanpage de facebook.
Vous avez le lien dans le descriptif avec, de toute manière, tous mes autres réseaux sociaux.
Passez une excellente journée, n'oubliez pas de laisser un petit commentaire, je les lis tous,
même si en ce moment, j'ai un petit peu moins le temps de répondre, je les lis vraiment tous.
N'oubliez pas de vous abonner avant de partir et rendez-vous demain à 17h. Ciao!